- HEY, GUYS.
FIRST OF ALL,
I JUST WANT TO SAY
WE ARE GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
IT'S BEEN GREAT.
- YES, AND WE HAVE NOTICED
THAT YOU HAVE GOTTEN VERY...
C-COMFORTABLE,
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY COMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR COMFORTABLENESS.
- I'M SO COMFORTABLE
WITH YOU GUYS BEING HERE,
BUT BE CAREFUL.
'CAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
INJURING YOURSELVES AT NIGHT
WHEN YOU'RE WORKING OUT,
AND NIGHTTIME'S A VERY
DANGEROUS TIME TO WORK OUT.
- ANYWAY, UH,
GIVEN, YOU KNOW,
THE EVENTS
OF THE LAST DAY OR SO,
WE'VE REVISED THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAD THE OTHER DAY
TO SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE APROPOS.
ADAM.
WE GIVE YOU...
THE GAYLORD'S FORCE!
- HA-HA?
THE GAYLORD'S FORCE.
IF YOU CAN TAKE
THE PAIN OF A MAN'S UNIT
PRESSING INTO YOUR [bleep],
YOU'VE GOT THE STRENGTH
TO DO ANYTHING.
- IS ONE SLOGAN
THAT WE'RE TOYING WITH.
- YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN THIS T-SHIRT,
AND I DON'T APPROVE OF IT.
OKAY? BUT I WILL
BE A JUNIOR MEMBER OF THE CREW,
SO, I SHOULD PROBABLY
AUDITION FOR YOU RIGHT NOW.
CHECK THIS OUT.
FROOT LOOPS EVERYWHERE!
- WHOO!
- YEAH. AND I'M GEARING UP
FOR THE REAL THING!
A FREAKIN' PHONE BOOK!
LET'S DO THIS!
- GIVE IT TO 'EM, ADAM.
- I DON'T HAVE
MY PHONE BOOK HERE.
I'M SO SORRY. I DON'T HAVE IT.
- GET THE PHONE BOOK.
- HURRY UP, HURRY UP.
- SO, YOU SEE WHERE
WE'RE GOING WITH THIS, RIGHT?
IT'S BASICALLY A POWERFUL,
HEALTHY MESSAGE
THAT BEING GAY
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE WEAK,
OR, UM...
- MMM...
- OKAY, WHAT'RE YOU DOING?
- ARE YOU HAVING SEX
WITH EACH OTHER?
- WE'RE NOT HAVING SEX.
WE'RE JUST...
SOAKING.
- [chuckles]
YEAH, BUT I THINK
THIS SOAK
IS ABOUT TO TURN
INTO A POWER WASH,
SO, IF YOU BOYS
WOULDN'T MIND SCOOTING ALONG.
- OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
- [clears throat]
- I DON'T MIND HAVING YOU HERE.
RIGHT?
I DON'T EVEN MIND ALL
THE SUCKIN', AND THE SCREWIN',
AND THE SCREAMIN'
WHEN YOU EJAC.
BUT I NEED TO KNOW IF YOU WANNA
BE A PART OF THIS SHOW OR NOT.
'CAUSE IF YOU DO, I NEED YOU
TO PULL OUT OF HIS [bleep]
AND GET TO WORKING!
DO YOU GET ME?
- OKAY, OKAY, RELAX.
SOUNDS COOL.
- WE'RE INTERESTED.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YEAH!
OH, OH, HAND CRAMP.
HAND CRAMP. THAT HURTS.